what up space fam golson here from anime
out pro back at it again to discuss
every mythical zone user this time the
most hyped category of devil fruits in
my humble opinion i published a more
general all zone user than the powers
explained video about two years ago
which you can check out as well link in
the description but this one will be a
more updated and detailed version for
mythical zone fruits in particular if
you do enjoy seeing these one-piece
videos and want to keep them coming the
best thing you could do is channel the
pirate king within and smash that like
button with no mercy if you haven't make
this the video you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and if you're new to
nakama let me know and say hi below in
the comments now a quick thank you to
rage shadow legends for sponsoring this
video do you ever feel like you just
haven't accomplished as much in life as
your average isekai protagonist what if
i told you that you can take down the
demon lord crush the ice golem ascend
doom tower and meet beautiful waifus
right now raid is a free-to-play game
available both on mobile and pc with
raid you can explore millions of
champion combinations and master
countless tactics as you take on raid
bosses dungeon runs campaign battles and
pvp arena matches and now for a limited
time only the one and only ninja is
available as a champion for free but
he's only going to be available until
october 15th he's a super limited
edition champion so when the time is up
you'll never be able to get ninja again
so you gotta start playing right now if
you want to get a huge head start in
raid all you have to do is hit the top
link in the description or scan the qr
code right here new players will get an
epic hero to noru 200k silver one xp
boost one energy refill and one ancient
shard so you can summon an awesome
champion as soon as you get in game you
will find your extra rewards here in
your inbox for the next 30 days only so
click the top link in the description
right now now without further ado let's
jump into it spoilers and all let's
start things off with one of
blackbeard's 10 titanic commanders
crescent moon hunter katarina devin she
ate the inuinomi model kyubi no kitsune
for pokemon and naruto fans it's pretty
much the nine-tailed fox fruit and in
the viz manga is called the dog dog
fruit mythical type model nine-tailed
fox devin is 36 years old after the time
skip and her current bounty is unknown
but we do know that she's a whopping 11
foot 10 inches tall or 361 centimeters
she can use her fruit to transform into
a nine-tailed fox and perhaps more
interestingly she can use the power to
transform herself into anyone and
impersonate them during chapter 925 we
saw the fruit in action when she used it
to impersonate absalom tricking gekko
more into thinking that his man was
still alive she does transform back
after it's revealed that absalom is dead
and that shiryu stole the clear clear
fruit it's the best fruit for disguising
yourself as someone else because it
allows the user to transform their
clothes as well unlike the clone clone
fruit that covers devon and the
nine-tailed fox fruit for now we haven't
seen a lot of it so far but we're sure
to learn more about this interesting
mythical fruit as the story progresses
for number two we got the corrupted
shogun of wano kurozumi orochi and his
heavy hebinomi model yamata no orochi
another fruit that might remind you of
naruto specifically of rochimaru its
english name is the snake snake fruit
model yamata no orochi and it's based on
an eight-headed serpent-slash-dragon in
japanese mythology this fruit lets
orochi transform into a giant 8-headed
serpent we've seen that orochi can
easily grab and trap a person within the
jaws of one of his serpent heads having
8 heads also lets you attack multiple
people at once which is also useful the
fruit as many of us predict it also lets
you survive being beheaded one mythical
parallel of the yamata no orochi is the
hydra in her achilles and most of us may
remember that cutting off one of its
heads never did the trick in fact in
that example multiple heads would grow
back to replace the first at one point
kaido beheads orochi which wasn't that
surprising after all why would such a
strong figure want to keep someone as
annoying cowardly and proud as orochi
around longer than necessary later
orochi recovered somehow and then ran
into the red scabbards fukurokuju
informed him that the red scabbards
didn't even know that he'd already died
once at kaido's hand what might have
been a crazy reveal to them ended up
being an anticlimactic but hilarious
revenge after aurorachi transformed into
his eight-headed form and arrogantly
talked about how he would finish off the
injured red scabbards the scabbards went
on to slice off all of his heads
effortlessly commenting on how they have
no time to waste on the likes of orochi
now this could potentially be his end
because all the heads were cut off at
once or it could be like the hydra in
hercules and they may be able to grow
back nonetheless we don't know for sure
right now but almost anything is
possible when mythical zones are in
question so i honestly wouldn't be
surprised if he survived the attacks in
the end the yamata no orochi is a very
interesting fruit with unique abilities
like most mythical zoned fruits but cool
fruits don't always go to cool or even
strong characters and this is one of
those times although i found the fruit
pretty fascinating orochi himself was
definitely not worthy of the mythical
fruit for number three let's look at a
character who is definitely worthy of
his mythical zone fruit dr marco the
phoenix marco is as legendary as yonko
commanders come he was the right hand
man to whitebeard the man called the
strongest in the world and the closest
to the one piece he is currently 45
years old and his birthday isn't october
like mine coincidence i think not he's
six foot eight inches tall and his
bounty is 1.374 billion berries a bounty
bigger than queen's impressive bounty of
1.32 billion so even among yaakov
commanders his bounty is top tier
although it's possible that king himself
could have a greater bounty when it's
finally revealed of course marco the
phoenix has the phoenix fruit more
specifically the toritori no me model
phoenix or the bird bird fruit model
phoenix another way to translate it is
as immortal bird another hype detail
about the mythical fruit back in chapter
553 we first saw marco use his ability
and it was to deflect an admiral's
attack no less without breaking a sweat
marco's fruit allows him to adopt the
properties of a phoenix and to
straight-up fully transform into a blue
phoenix marco's blue flames allow him to
heal himself or others this is one of
the reasons that the immortal bird
translation is so apt because marco can
seemingly heal from otherwise lethal
wounds using blue flames it looks kind
of like an enhanced logia because marco
can take hits as if they just went
through him but in his case he could
also use the blue flames to heal from
hockey infused attacks as well as
mentioned marco could block admiral
kizaru's attack and he also successfully
blocked admiral akai news as well during
the paramount war and he would later
have no lasting damage showing just how
superior this fruit is to let's say asus
flame flame fruit which was easily
overpowered by a kainu marco was able to
use his fruit for a while to also hold
his own while fighting against king and
queen at the same time two yonko
commanders with both confirmed bounties
over a billion berries even though we
don't know king's exact bounty obviously
this doesn't mean he could actually beat
them both at the same time and peros
pero pointed out that he looked
exhausted but it's still very impressive
nonetheless considering how good of a
fighter marco is in battle it's all the
more impressive that he can be just as
helpful when it comes to healing others
we've seen him use his flames to help
heal others and more specifically he's
used them as a way to help prevent the
further spread of queen's virus in many
people notably marco's flames won't burn
you as they burn unlike conventional
flames but they can definitely be used
to reinforce the power of his attacks so
the op power comes with both offensive
defensive and healing capabilities
notably oda has told us that marco's
healing has limitations in a question
corner so he's not necessarily immortal
in his phoenix form it's quite likely
that if marco drains all his stamina he
won't be able to use the healing powers
which might explain why he sometimes
leaves minor wounds like scratches or
bruises unhealed in battle another way
marco could definitely be defeated is if
you expose him to seastone then he won't
be able to use his regeneration on
lethal wounds it should be said that
marco's forces fought against
blackbeard's forces in the payback war
about a year after the paramount war and
marco's side was obliterated even so
marco made it out fine without suffering
lasting wounds thanks to his phoenix
powers but i think that's enough about
marco for the purposes of this video his
mythical fruit is one of my favorites
and though it does have its limits which
makes sense it has let marco at the very
least exchange blows with many of the
best fighters in the world without
taking any lasting damage next up we
have kaido himself the leader of the
beast pirates and the man called the
strongest creature in the world kaido's
bounty is over 4.6 billion berries
meaning among the living yonko he has
the highest bounty so the question was
for a long time what exact devil fruit
did kaido have what mythical zone is
worthy of going to the leader who stands
at the apex of the animal kingdom that
is the beast pirates there were theories
that he had a straightforward dragon
fruit even theories that he was a dragon
and had a kind of human fruit but during
chapter 999 big mom revealed that on the
day rox fell into ruin at god valley she
gave kaido a legendary model of the fish
fish fruit and she even says because of
that kaido owes her his life that's how
big of a favor this fruit was in her
view the official name of the legendary
mythical fish fish fruit was given to us
in a data book and it is the uo uhnomi
model seryu or the fish fish fruit model
seryu the seryu is an azure dragon and
if this at first confuses you how a fish
fish fruit can turn into a dragon just
think of magikarp and gyarados in
pokemon gyarados 2 is based off of the
japanese series which is in turn based
off a chinese myth specifically there's
a chinese dragon gate myth where there's
this giant waterfall and if a carp is
able to persevere and make it all the
way to the top of the practically
impossible to climb waterfall it becomes
a dragon and back to the question if
this is a fitting fruit for the world's
strongest creature it definitely seems
to be since eastern dragons like this
one were often considered to be
extremely powerful and were even
worshiped as gods but back to kaido's
specific powers we often see him
transform into his azure dragon form and
more recently we've even gotten to see
his hybrid form which is accompanied by
a very cool tale overall i really like
the aesthetics of his hybrid form
kaido's dragon form is the biggest zone
transformation we've seen and he
absolutely dominates the skyline when
he's flying overhead his dragon form is
so big and powerful that it stated he
could obliterate all of kuri if he
thrashes about in a drunken stupor while
in his dragon form thus without even
trying to he could destroy an entire
region of a country the insane
durability of his mythical scales has
also been noted multiple times during
chapter 923 luffy hit kaido many times
with haki enhanced attacks and although
they landed and looked painful kaido got
up unscathed like absolutely nothing
happened and went on to take out luffy
with one quick blow it's also been said
about kaido's fruit that it gives kaido
access to more supernatural abilities
than any other mythical zone we've seen
so far one such ability is that he can
create flame clouds that for all intents
and purposes allow him to fly and can
even lift up an entire island and turn
it into a flying castle additionally
kaido has been seen launching
devastating fire blasts from his mouth
in dragon mode and hybrid mode and the
list goes on this truly godlike creature
has turned his roar into lightning he
has released blades of wind strong
enough to cut off a red scabbard's arm
and he's been able to summon multiple
tornadoes which led to zorro labeling
him a natural disaster it seems like in
close combat kaido's hybrid form is the
most powerful since he saves that form
for last he's not unheard-able because
attacks that can bypass his tough scales
can cause harm like advanced hockey
infused attacks and opeope no me
surgical techniques and so on after all
odin did succeed in leaving a huge
lasting scar on him still there's no
doubt that this is one of the best devil
fruits of all and arguably the strongest
mythical zone fruit there is it even
makes the sea a usual devil fruit
weakness a non-issue because the dragon
form can just fly over it i think that's
enough kaido for this video because we
do have others to cover but let's just
say this fruit did not disappoint in the
least next let's look at sengoku the
former fleet admiral and living legend
he was one of the major figures back
during goldie rogers time along with
whitebeard shiki and garp after the time
skip this dude is 79 years old he has an
especially interesting mythical zone
fruit namely the hitohito no me model
daibutsu or the human human fruit model
buddha he has the ability to transform
into a giant gold buddha during chapter
578 at marine ford we see his giant form
launch shock waves at blackbeard
blackbeard and his crew are shown to be
rattled by the attack whited out eyes
blood and all that jazz but obviously
the attack doesn't keep blackbeard down
obviously sengoku's size and physical
power in this form are great and
although he failed to execute ace with a
punch thanks to luffy's inflated stomach
and a candle wall his power still led to
the execution platform collapsing and
that is it for sengoku we haven't seen
much of his power in action but what we
have seen was no doubt epic definitely a
power fitting for a former fleet admiral
next up we have yamato kaido's child and
number one odin fan as us weekly manga
readers found out recently yamato also
has a mythical zone fruit namely the
inuinu no me model okuchi no makami or
the dog dog fruit model okuchino makami
we're told it is a rare mythical wolf
and that it is a guardian spirit of wano
and that makes it all the more painful
for kaido that yamato is using it and
claiming to be odin the fruit lets
yamato turn into a wolf god pretty much
and we've seen the cool looking hybrid
form clash with kaido's own hybrid form
not only is it clearly mythical and
powerful it's also very valuable because
of its symbolic value for wano
specifically it'll obviously be easier
to rule a country if their guardian
deity is supporting you rather than
challenging your authority another hype
fact is that kaido says he worked hard
to acquire that devil fruit and whenever
yonko worked hard to acquire specific
fruit like black bear with the dark dark
fruit and shanks with the gomu gomu no
me it's always a sign that the fruit is
an especially big deal keep in mind this
is not just a mythical zone but a
carnivorous mythical zone making the
fruit especially well suited for combat
and it would have to be special to allow
one to repeatedly clash with the
so-called world's strongest creature in
his op hybrid form we saw how quickly
kaido took out luffy the first time so
the fact that yamato can occupy the anko
for so long while he's in his strongest
form is no small feat we've also seen
yamato fire a mouth blast called namuji
glacier fang at kaido and that was met
with one of his own blast breaths and
the attacks canceled each other out it's
an interesting attack name that lends a
fire versus ice dynamic to the kaido vs
yamato fight yamato's mythical fruit did
not disappoint and as i've said many
times i would love to have a mythical
zone user like yamato join the straw hat
crew my only concern is that it wouldn't
make much sense symbolically for the
guardian deity of wano to leave the
island but we'll see what happens so
those are all the canon fruits and i
could stop the video right here but for
those who perfectly remember all the
details about all the mythical zone
users and additionally remember
everything they've read about them in
otis question corners i do have some
bonus mythical zone fruits for you so
even you the most hardcore fans just
might learn something new about one
piece in this video let's start the
non-canon fruits off with the bato bato
no me model vampire aka the bat bat
fruit model vampire this fruit gives its
user patrick redfield the ability to
turn into a you guessed it vampire this
character was designed by oda himself
and serves as the main antagonist of the
one piece unlimited world red game again
this is non-canon but according to
sengoku redfield was powerful enough to
rival the pirate king in his prime a
very hype statement with his unique
mythical zone powers redfield can
sharpen his teeth and use them to you
guessed it suck the blood out of his
enemies they age quickly as a result
while he becomes stronger and through
these means gains access to eternal
youth next up we have the toritorinomi
model nue aka the bird bird fruit model
nue this fruit was featured in the one
piece art nue a series of artwork
created for the one piece x kyoto event
in 2017 that depicts a non-canon story
of the straw hats in wano the fruit was
eaten by toratsugu a resident of wano
which is fitting because the nue is a
mythical japanese yokai it's a
chemerical beast that borrows different
body parts from different animals for
instance it has the face of a monkey the
body of a tiger the mane of a lion and a
snake for a tail when toratsugu
transforms into the yokai he has the
ability to fly but is nevertheless
overpowered relatively quickly by luffy
oda himself drew the climactic scene
where luffy battles the nue for the
final mythical zone user we turn to a
video game again specifically to one
piece unlimited world red again in this
video game we also find out about inui
no no model baked danuki literally
translated to dog dog fruit model
monster raccoon dog it allows its user
to transform into a tanuki monster and
it was eaten by get this a pen once
again oda designed the mythical zone pen
called pato and pato belongs to the
already mentioned patrick redfield potto
may not be the most op mythical zone
user but he's definitely interesting he
can use the tip of his tail to write and
furthermore has the ability to transform
leaves into objects and people by riding
on them and that is it all nine mythical
zone users from one piece video games
and art exhibitions included and their
powers explained thank you so much for
staying tuned until the end and let me
know which mythical zone you'd want it
could be from this list or you could
pick from a myth that we haven't seen
yet in one piece if you did enjoy this
video and want to keep them coming the
best thing you could do is channel the
pirate king within and smash that like
button with no mercy if you haven't make
this the video you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and while you wait for
the next video to drop feel free to
check out my growing one-piece playlist
that includes videos on all the fruits
yonko warlords and much much more link
to that is in the description and if you
don't see a video you'd really like me
to cover in the playlist then suggest it
in the comments and until next time see
ya space cowboys
[Music]
my